bonjour à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation la manif pour tous des
fils donc aujourd'hui en compagnie de 21
autres associations est-ce que vous avez
espoirs de peser sur le sénat qui va
examiner mardi le projet de loi
bioéthique
écoutez oui bien sûr que nous organisons
cette manifestation parce que nous avons
bien espoirs de peser c'est à dire que
ce projet de loi n'est pas sans un
projet bioéthique c'est un projet anti
éthique dont la plupart de ces articles
et donc nous appelons les sénateurs à
une réécriture très en profondeur une
réécriture très complète et tout en
demandant de toute façon à emmanuel
macron le retrait de ce projet de loi
parce qu'à vrai dire la réécriture est
tellement importante affaire qu'il
vaudrait mieux le retirer et tout
reprendre sur de nouvelles bases et des
bases bien sûr de fraternité de
solidarité d'éthique de respect de des
personnes de respect de l'humain tout
simplement parce que là on n'y est pas
du tout alors pourquoi cette opposition
que l'on considérait radicale à la pma
pour toussaint
alors ça n'a rien de radical ou alors
dans le bon sens du terme de la
radicalité c'est à dire que
courageusement avec cohérence avec
générosité
beaucoup de personnes aujourd'hui vont
nous rejoindre pour exprimer le fait que
ce te ce projet de loi n'est pas
acceptable
et j'ajoute d'ailleurs que 51% des
français dans un sondage ifop de cette
semaine ont estimé ont déclaré être en
faveur du retrait eux aussi de ce projet
de loi de bioéthique et chez les jeunes
c'est même une majorité massive ses 64 %
des 18-24 ans qui eux souhaitent le
retrait de ce projet de loi est donc
nous sommes immensément nombreux
j'espère que nous serons très nombreux
tout à l'heure à partir de 13 heures à
partir de la place de la résistance à
paris pour exposer publiquement notre
préoccupation et l'urgence de ce retrait
du projet de loi
alors pour l'instant concernant les
amendements retenus qui vont dans votre
sang celui pour l'accès la pma relatifs
aux critères d'infertilité qui a été
retenu tout comme la suppression du
remboursement par la sécurité sociale
est ce que ce sont des avancées dans
votre combat contre la paix m
alors il ya d'ailleurs hâte renforcement
de l'interdiction de la gestation pour
autrui qui a été votée par la commission
spéciale du sénat
mais à vrai dire d'abord c'est la séance
publique du sénat en première lecture à
partir de mardi 21 qui sera réellement
importante
et puis par ailleurs vous avez vous
évoqué le fait qu'on m'a remis un
critère de pathologie de la fertilité
mais seulement pour le couple homme
femme
il n'en reste pas moins qu'aujourd'hui
tel quel le projet de loi à ce jour la
procréation médicalement assistée serait
bien ouverte aux couples de femmes et
aux femmes seules et donc le projet de
loi disent toujours à faire sciemment
volontairement des orphelins de père d
avant leur conception
et c'est évidemment inacceptable un père
c'est important dans la vie d'un enfant
et d'un jeune et on ne peut pas faire
comme si c'était accessoires du
secondaire d'avoir un père et puis dans
le projet de loi il y a toujours encore
aujourd'hui l'inscription prévu de deux
mamans sur l'acte de naissance d'un
enfant est évidemment c'est fictif c'est
aberrant c'est faux on ne peut pas
intégrer
on ne peut pas créer ainsi une filiation
bidon une filiation fictive la filiation
ce sens bien précis et la république
française l'état ne peut pas entériner
n'importe quoi alors tous les
amendements qui demande la suppression
de la pma pour toutes ont été rejetées
on voit une montée aussi des pros pma
est ce que vous n'avez pas l'impression
d'avoir perdu la bataille
alors du côté de la commission spéciale
il y a eu au contraire au cours des
débats et des auditions entre guillemets
un progrès qui a été fait parce que au
début on partait plutôt d'un tient deux
sénateurs opposés à la paix à mme à son
père et finalement à la fin
le vote a donné 14 voix contre la pma
son père et 18 voix pour la pma son père
donc malheureusement s'est passé mais
vous voyez à force de réflexion et quand
on veut bien ouvrir les sujets et y
réfléchir on peut ou non à certains élus
arrivent à sortir de la posture
idéologique et ils comprennent aussi
tous les enjeux de fric tous les enjeux
de business qu'il ya derrière ce qui est
un marché de la procréation bien sûr qui
aujourd'hui dans le monde à peu près 130
milliards d'euros ils entendent aussi
pour certains que c'est un détournement
de la médecine et toute cette question
qui sont l'arrière-plan du projet de loi
et y compris sa logique trans humaniste
et bien certains en prennent conscience
et véritablement nous allons insister
réinsisté toute la journée d'aujourd'hui
est bien sûr toute la semaine prochaine
sur tous ces aspects sur tous ces points
et en appelant les sénateurs à faire
preuve de sagesse
puisqu'on parle souvent de la sagesse du
plus grand recul des sénateurs il a vidé
projet de loi est bien que cette fois ci
à nouveau ils fassent preuve de sagesse
de courage parce que effectivement il
faut oser aller peut-être contraint
certains vents dominants mais peu
importe l'histoire de toute façon nous
donnera raison j'en suis et nous en
sommes convaincus ce que nous
souhaiterions ce ne pas perdre des
années avec une loi qui passerait et qui
serait source de souffrance
d'aberrations et des dealers il nous
faut vraiment ce retrait du projet de
loi de bioéthique avant de s'embarquer
dans ses pratiques catastrophique et
vous voyez dans le domaine de l'écologie
où on a depuis des années fait n'importe
quoi utiliser toutes les techniques
possibles sans se poser de questions
tout ça aussi avec des enjeux financiers
très importants et tout ça pour des
raisons de désir et de confort et tout
est aujourd'hui on se rend compte que
nous avons fait des dégâts considérables
à la planète aux espèces animales aux
espèces végétales et caetera et caetera
et nous
arrivons pas à rétablir la situation
ludivine les deux minutes au coeur bien
d'anthologie et pour l'humain on ne peut
pas se lancer dans n'importe quoi ce
n'est pas possible
très rapidement les devine de la
recherche en défendant votre position
vous ne craignez pas justement d'être
associé à l'extrémisme hacker
l'extrémisme même si l'on qu'un enfant a
besoin d'un père et d'une mère tous les
sens formel d'un homme et d'une femme et
cet homme et cette femme son père et sa
mère et l'enfant a besoin d'eux est
évidemment un père et une mère c'est
extrêmement important dans la vie est
une mère ne remplace pas un père et
réciproquement
alors peut-être que certains appellent
ça de l'extrémisme mais je pense qu'ils
sont véritablement dans l'obscurantisme
et que le progrès ne peut pas être de
nier la science de nier la réalité
humaine et de nier évidemment les
besoins les plus fondamentaux de
l'enfant
ça c'est véritablement de
l'obscurantisme et nous défendons une
vision moderne et nous sommes là
préoccupé engagé impliqués pour le monde
de demain pour les générations à venir
merci beaucoup lui devine de la
recherche rappelle que vous êtes
présidente de la manif pour tous